let me begin with this last week you
were on Twitter talking about Donald
Trump's economic plan you were
subsequently out on Twitter urging
people to read it and recommending it as
the solution to America's economy
yesterday you were sparring with Mark
Cuban on Twitter about the presidential
campaign Hillary versus Donald and now I
understand you're talking about starting
a super PAC that would effectively be
pro Trump does this mean that Carl Icahn
is finally some would say about to throw
his weight and perhaps money around in
this presidential campaign well I think
I made it pretty clear all through the
campaign right at the beginning that I
think Trump's policies are possibly the
only thing that's going to save us from
going down this decline that we're in on
productivity which is very important in
this country I really think that we've
we've had a tremendous decline in
capital spending which everybody knows
I'm not bringing that up and a major
decline in productivity growth now if
you think about that I think one of the
major reasons for it and I'm a little
microcosm of it is that some of these
regulatory agencies the EPA in
particular and certain things I I'm not
against regulation I think certain
regulation is very important I'm not
even getting some of the financial
regulation of the job I think that that
some of the investment banks really
caused a lot of problems at oh I but I
am against what I consider to be just
arbitrary and capricious regulation such
as what the EPA is now doing concerning
refineries so that's a microcosm of what
I'm talking about which absolutely
scares business their business looks at
this as a war between business and
government and therefore Eric today what
happens is that a CEO and even a
mediocre CEO and I'm certainly no fan of
mediocre CEOs there are very good ones
but many mediocre ones that take that
that go way in and say okay we got the
greatest Vantage of zero interest rates
and we
borrow money buy back stock instead of
investing in capital which gets their
stock up they vested they make 50 100
million bucks or whatever they make is
they go play golf the rest of the lives
and to work us the middle-class worker
suffers greatly from it which they are
today and you you need someone to come
in with a fresh broom and in certain
cases with these regulatory agencies
take hold of what they're doing and
showing business that we're not against
okay that's why I'm for Trump and that's
the whole story you know in a nutshell
what I understand that what I was
getting at with the question and perhaps
I didn't articulate it well enough is
I'd like to know more and I think there
are lots of other people who'd like to
know more about what you're going to do
beyond endorsing Donald Trump the way
that you have talking up his economic
plan the way that you have are we going
to see a super PAC if I do what I am I
am considering it at this moment in time
but I am doing at this moment in time is
really moving against some of the
regulations that the EPA has an octane
they've been wiped under the rug but III
think that completely is totally illegal
we are they're going against refineries
and you're going to see in this country
a lot of smaller refineries go bankrupt
as a result of these regulations where
these refineries have simply to make it
simple on this TV show cause it's a
little more arcane you know uh penalize
for something that they can't do they're
asked they're saying that they're
responsible for blending with ethanol
that's fine except nobody will buy the
gasoline that we blend with ethanol I my
own refineries obviously I have an
agenda here but you know that doesn't
matter it nobody here is really standing
up to what the EPA is doing so that's
just one little example of what is wrong
with our economy and that's all I'm
saying so I'm really getting involved in
that at this moment in time and I am i
bill and I didn't go on the economic
committee as you maybe know I don't know
because it gives me the room to do a
pack and we're considering that too and
I think we will do one I don't want to
say I'm definitely doing it until I am
doing it but I am so
means that we came out with a big paper
and we're going to continue really
literally to fight what the EPA is doing
we think we think it's illegal but what
more than that it's well hey I think
it's reprehensible it's one thing to
write a letter to the EPA it's another
thing to start a super PAC that would
challenge some of the regulations that
that you find so chaffing it's another
thing wouldn't you agree to conflate
some concerns that you have about
specific and as you put it arcane we D
regulations that are in place governing
refineries and renewable fuels with a
whole presidential campaign isn't it
it certainly is it certainly is but but
they're not mutually exclusive obviously
and I don't want to say on this program
that I'm going to invest twenty million
dollars it is a super PAC until as we
speak I am talking to the I'm actually
talking tonight to the people though it
would be working with me on the PAC
however being that said I don't want to
say something here that you could call
me back a month from now two months
around how come you never did what you
said you were gonna do so I'm not just
good I'm not gonna say it to you now I
am saying to you that we are going to be
in a in a shall we say argument with EPA
it don't get me wrong because I believe
some of the stuff the EPA does does is
salutary I think it's necessary in fact
but what they're doing here
I don't I honestly can't understand it
you know I've been in fights with
companies all my life my business life
well I think what they do is is wrong
I think it's dysfunctional but there's
always a good argument there is no a
good argument for what the EPA is doing
I mean this is about you know I fought
US Steel in the old days at forward Tom
Warner right for it as you know with so
many companies and you know at the risk
of being a modest make billions of
billions of billions for for investors
now if you're gonna say to me what God
didn't you make a like yourself well
sure I guess that's that's you know this
is what the economy this is what our
capitalist system is about you incentive
but what I'm trying to tell you is I've
never seen anything as absurd
that's what the EPA is million here let
me ask you this then what matters to you
more right now today as we speak
making or somehow forcing the EPA to
make these changes whether it's through
the power of your pen the people who
might be watching this conversation or a
super PAC
you could start or so it's on the one
hand I'm asking you what's more
important getting the EPA to change
putting Donald Trump in office I want to
know where they usually exclusive no I
recognize that and again I'd very much
like to see Trump win this because I
think he is the only hope to save
business in America the way we know it I
really mean that Eric I mean I think
that right now our economy is really not
doing well you see GDP is not going up I
could give you a lot of reasons but the
most important is that the middle-class
worker is really doesn't not have good
jobs this unemployment numbers are we
are not accurate in one way that took me
a lot of a lot of these guys have left
the workforce at to these jobs aren't
paying that well you know it so I am
saying that the middle class that is why
you saw this uprising you know for
Bernie Sanders and and you see it for
Trump and you see brexit have you seen
what's going on in Italy I think there's
an undercurrent of great distressed in
our global economies you know this 1%
people resent it and they resent
government for allowing it to happen by
the way the EPA in this rule in this
very small rule is helping Big Oil which
I don't even think they have the specter
healthy they're helping Big Oil and and
they're helping a couple of very wealthy
companies make a fortune and putting the
smaller refineries out of business ok
that alone you could say so big deal but
that is why there is distrust of what is
happening in government and this is what
I'd like to do something about and if I
believed I could make a difference with
Trump I'll do it but I have to really
believe up go to make a difference well
let's talk about that for a moment
because you threw a number out there for
what you might spend on a super PAC 20
million dollars
what would it take for you to spend more
money on the Trump campaign because to
my knowledge thus far you've only spent
a hundred grand which may be a lot to
some people but to a certain ways I
supported a IIb you know wasn't they had
that when he had that rally for the
veterans which would they're great the
veterans are important anyway so I would
have done it but I gave a half a million
immediately when they asked me to at
that at that
that evening thing you know when he went
against megyn kelly I think it is so in
other words I did a few lines of things
but being that said I'm not looking for
praise for that what I am saying to you
though is I want to really believe that
Donald has a shot to win and you don't I
I do believe it I do believe it the way
you've said your it sounds as though
you're trying to persuade yourself that
he has a shot you know you know
something
and maybe I shouldn't be saying on a
bluebird but I will say it that I do
believe that Donald has a great shot if
he sticks to the positives not so much
to the negatives meaning if he just
talks about the economy and what I'm
saying and tell the worker he knows it's
no swing state hey look here's the thing
you know Hillary Clinton's making all
these promises I mean I'm gonna give you
broadband for everybody I'm gonna do
tunnels or bridges and all that where's
she gonna get the money it got a divided
Congress in gridlock she's not gonna get
the money so she could promise anything
into some expense you could say darlin
compromise or two but the one thing yet
no Donald can redeliver is he can change
the regulatory agencies as president he
doesn't need Congress you gotta look at
things yet only Congress for he doesn't
need them about immigration and by the
way you know he I think it's a little
bit ludicrous to let people come into
this country for the Middle East that
tell you had been looking to you know
that Isis was telling you to look at the
killer yeah let these people come in so
these are the things he could deliver
and that's what he's got to stick to but
why isn't he listening to you I have to
presume that you're offering him this
vice you and he saw each other this past
weekend did you not tell him well this
week it was pretty quick I mean I came
in left but I do talk to him and I do it
I am going to keep talking to her about
it and I want and he knows this too that
he's look I think Donald is great what
he speaks about these things
I think it's an economic message Monday
at 2 Monday's ago was terrific but if he
sticks to that he's gonna win but and I
am good at every I people telling them
hey you down on the polls because to get
all this you know negativity and
arguments and even negativity where it
is factual you do and so that's one
reason I will do a pack that's negative
against Hillary Clinton I do a pack
that's positive about Donald Trump and
his economics you know beliefs and and
this is where you're asking and maybe
I'm saying too much
I think Donald's great I think he'd be a
great president I believe it a lot of my
friends don't you know a lot of my
friends are mad at me for this but I
believe it and I believe he would do it
he's exactly what this country needs but
what he has to do is get that economic
message across instead of just you know
talking glibly about about issues that
really you know go meet al carro why
isn't he listening to you why isn't he
listening to Tom Barrett who told me the
very same thing yesterday well you know
why I don't know in kind of a
problematic position doesn't it look you
know you got strong point a strong point
back Donald is you got a strong
personality believes in himself and
that's really good I know up he is he is
a he will build a consensus of Congress
hey look good negative criticism you
could make about anyone but but that is
what I think is becoming a problem and
so if he will just get on that positive
note about this economy he'll witness
election because the middle class
American I believe there's a great
undercurrent they are very disabuse
about what's going on hey look
I invest a great deal of money I own 20
companies I've turned him around it was
it with negative they were dying we
cleaned them up made we we have 93
thousands of people working for us at
IEP you know but here's the issue that
right now literally I've cut down
capital spending and I'm scared of it
would I see what the EPA is doing on
this stuff and if I'm scared
can you imagine what all these smaller
businesses are they are killing
middle-middle small business and we're
Clinton hasn't said one word against
some of these crazy regulations well you
know I'm not the only one saying a lot
of the regulations they they've run amok
you run amok now let me write this maybe
I want to make it clear there are great
regulations there's some great
regulators and you need regulation in
fact I say that to the consternation of
some of the Wall Street friends I have
that you do need it and if you did if
you had better regulation you wouldn't
have had a wait but what they're doing
today has got crazy and that's why there
are no jobs for the middle class because
there's no capital spending
you have worn-out tools you may be right
Karl that Donald Trump can if you were
in the White House do some things on his
own exercising similar executive
authority that the president has and
over the last several years about
immigration you pointed out and
certainly in some respects about
regulation but he's made similar
promises to Hillary Clinton when it
comes to trade agreements and also on
infrastructure so are they not similarly
false promises if he has to Congress to
get help on those fronts okay a great
point yes you're right every president
you could go back to George Washington
probably has made promises they can't
keep
okay and and and I did Donald believes
he'll keep them because Donald believes
he'll build a consensus in Congress but
it's a question I agree exactly what
you're saying and and I think he has a
better chance of delivering on those
promises than Hillary Clinton
so therefore let's look at what he will
definitely deliver well he will
definitely deliver and this is the point
he should be making and you should make
what he will definitely deliver to the
middle-class worker
who's worried about his job and his that
manufacturing by the way would you stop
manufacturing in the country all this
other stuff is nonsense you know you
have a service economy so we're going to
just tweak to each other what are we
going to text each other that's all it's
great service economy eventually our
currency will go to hell and we will
lose our Germany so let's get back to my
point he can't know promise and keep
100% he'll keep this promise because I
know how he feels about it that he's
gonna stop these crazy regulations he
could do that first day in office I've
talked to him about it I've talked to a
team he's got about it that is a hundred
percent he can stop a lot of the crazy
immigration which i think is crazy
people said that you could argue i think
the regulations that you have i mean if
i wanted to go in to the stuff that he's
putting these smaller refineries out of
business but no reason the EPA is
putting out but absolutely no reason I
will say to you that he will stop that
that's a hundred percent that's what you
have to tell the swing state voter the
middle-class voter who wants jobs and is
sick and tired of the status quo today
and that's what he could do and if he
does that he'll win and one day I mean
III you know this program is difficult
to go in how it's saying Eric I can show
you some of these regulations I look I
fought us fear I fought hard wanna I
fought all these companies that you know
about and again the risk of be too
modest made billions for shale this may
be a lot of money for myself that's the
wrong with that but I will tell you I've
never seen anything as idiotic as some
of these rules that are being
promulgated right now by the EPA okay so
that's a quick essential example what's
wrong but there are many other examples
of what's wrong and that's why I've been
lazy what's another good one
a couple more anyway wait wait what's
wrong with these with the agencies look
at the NLRB look at some of the rulings
they make concerning labor I mean so
people are afraid really good deal with
I you know I I will tell you I have I
have a lot of unions work for me they're
fine some are terrible and and then some
gusts go off the reservation the NLRB
protects them okay but hey I'm not
against the NR a--
I mean look I I came from the streets of
Queens and I really do sympathize with
workers that many union workers people
think I'm too tough but I'm a tough guy
but but I'm not against that that but I
am against some of these we've gone way
too far in areas like that
now the FTC does a pretty good job of
what they do I'm not against them per se
I'm not fighting everywhere it's that I
believe in a lot of regulations and I've
had a lot of fighters they said fights
you know disagreements with some of my
as I'm saying Wall Street because I
think you do need regulation I think
they brought down did your best for
bankers well it's responsible okay if
you're so certain that I want to talk to
you about the economy for a moment
because your soul that Trump's economic
message is going to resonate with people
if he could just get beyond the
negativism as it were and talk about the
positives and talk about the things that
he's going to do then he would have that
shot that you believes he has he has at
the White House why is it that and this
may sound like a simplistic question
that's not intended to be why is it that
the stock market is where it is that
with valuations so high that I noticed
in a letter that or at least in a
statement that you made with your son
Brett earlier this month that you don't
feel confident making any large
investments absolutely Eric I think the
market and I've said it before hey look
I have hedges on I'm I was a voyage that
I ever was I ever was I I will tell you
there's certainly good companies it's
way over valued at twenty times the SP
and I'll tell you why
a lot of it is a result of zero interest
rates it's just what I said
you have zero interest and a lot of
buybacks money is not going into capital
so think of it as a rich family that
just has a lot of it this decides we're
just going to have a lot of fun we're
gonna sit around the pool and we'll keep
printed up io u--'s to the town we got a
good name you keep doing it until you go
broke and this is what's happening in
our economy zero interest rates are
building huge bubbles you have retirees
that saved a million bucks they're
familiar
it called me these friends of mine and
what do I do with my money I have to buy
stocks I said what why are you behind
sighs I can't live on 0% I said what's
better 0% or lose of 30% one day you can
lose it but they're doing it you've got
these bubbles building in real estate in
New York alone the real estate markets
through the roof it's coming down
somewhat now it's absurd and and
therefore I think the market is at
literally
very high levels because of zero
interest rates and if you really look at
it you know what the dollar is pretty
strong right now which has go to hurt
international earnings the SP you know
they live on international earnings
that's good to be hurt it was good to be
a day of reckoning here I've seen it
many times in my life when things look
good they look great you go into the sky
but that's when you have to really pull
down and and and really stop by being
that said I'm not going to take it's
gonna happen tomorrow and next week even
next month even next year possibly but
it's going to happen and you have to
change the direction of our economy that
so I can't say the plaintiff than that
and Trump will change it and bring in
and rein in some of the abuses I get
capital spend you know I look Hillary
Clinton said it she said it pretty well
let's unleash the great power of our
companies except the next sentence but
we could attack them we're going to
regulate them but all we're gonna get
them spending well how so it's a
mishmash of a contradiction your point
on capital spending maybe bang on a non
economist and so it's not my position to
say either way but I do have to point
out Karl that there are a few cynics out
there hearing you complain about
companies levering up to buy back stock
who remember unless I'm mistaken that
you have asked companies to do just that
on at least one notable occasion if not
more than one you're very right and let
me address it Apple we said they should
buy back stock and they made a great
deal of money doing it because Apple had
two hundred billion dollars sitting
there and they had an extra money
it didn't affect their capital spending
one iota and so and their stock was dirt
cheap when I told them to and as you
know I mean look again
you know I don't want to just be
boasting but I but we made we bought
Apple at one of the cheap prices and we
can I told Tim Cook hey you should just
buy back your stock you have all this
cash sitting there and I think I was
somewhat instrumental to get them to do
it but that doesn't mean that a lot of
these companies that are over levered
today and really not really what I
consider to be making sure Ernie's
borrowing money and buying back stock
this is making a false market but worse
than that it's cause it's costing them
it's causing them to have worn-out tools
for their workers it's costing them the
the ability to go into new things and
and therefore they should not be buying
back stock so it's like saying you have
two sons and you know what maybe one is
sickly or has asthma or something and
the other son is a great shape but a
great athlete so it's ok for him to go
swimming for three hours it's not ok for
the kid with a sport was I feeling well
to go do it therefore there are
companies that should buy back stock
you're a good regulators they're a good
regulation same idea there were good
CEOs but that doesn't mean that it you
know there's a broad brush here that you
go to use and you can't do that at least
I can't do it so that's my answer to
that when you say Karl that a day of
reckoning will come for the stock market
you can't say whether it's going to be
this week this month even this year or
next year let's talk about the factors
that you believe would precipitate such
a correction what caused stocks to fall
I think I've been talking about your
this whole interview but one of the
things that's caused it at the fall is
right happening right under your nose
that we have no capital spending what I
say on capitalist Penny's going way down
in a society like US manufacturing is
important I don't care
sooner or later you can't just keep
twitting to each other you can't text
each other that's what we said we're a
service economy oh that's great oh we're
a service economy what does that mean
that we tech support each other sooner
or later everybody is gonna sit next to
each other there's not wonderful so why
should anybody work just sit there in
text to each other or watch TV so I am
saying to you this is what is happening
as we speak there is no capital spending
is down obviously capital spending in
the last two years I mean it's just our
four percent of the last quarter which
is it we don't have a recession okay
productivity productivity is back grown
in fact it's the lowest point it's ever
been
as far as growth goes these are very
important things in a capitalistic
system and unless you have a
dictatorship but you're gonna go the way
of - but well - but was it dictation but
it's still wet that way but but then you
better go the way of Venezuela Argentina
you're gonna be in a major problem if
you keep doing I realize and I think
most people realize that unhealthy
economic conditions are not a recipe for
rising stock prices but for stocks to go
down people like you are going to have
to start selling and either moving your
money into fixed income or into cash you
said that you're more hedged than you've
ever been
but apart from a couple of small
dispositions you're not selling it right
well yet no not right I am I you know
it's obviously not helping my position
but I I have to admit I'm I'm sure a
great deal of ESP but I'm blowing more
than I'm sure I mean I can't help it
because I own so many companies that we
own we have assets and I've got a vest
with it and each one is unique I mean we
got a rail car fleet that stretches from
New York to Ohio I mean we got debt on
it all that these are companies I built
over the e'terica and are you proud of
them we own a number of companies that I
just bought Pep Boys I think there's a
future that I won't go into that on this
TV but I that doesn't mean I own these
companies I think they'll survive and do
okay look I own the refineries and we're
unhappy about what the hell is going on
but look I bought it at a cheap price
and we got the power to stay alive but
it's going to be very bad in that in
that industry but what I am willing to
get back to my point I don't think it
has to be people like me I think it's
just builds on itself I've seen it
happen before where you suddenly start
realizing that these companies really
don't have true earning power and then
fund managers start selling and once
that debacle slide happens it's gonna be
pretty bad and I think it will
one day but you know I there was nobody
the world there's too many variables to
be able to predict when and where it's
gonna happen you just that's that's just
just a dis same way to spend your time
so I I will just tell you that we have a
problem and Hillary Clinton will make it
worse because she believes in big big
big government but you must and she said
it unleash the power of companies in
this country where we we are a
capitalistic system and you have to have
companies that invest and have faith in
their governments and over the last
eight years we become more and more at
war with our governments our companies
and you don't see this really spending
now you can say technology companies are
spending but when is that going to come
to fruition maybe is it years away
actually ironically it's happened a
little sooner than you think because you
got more and more people walking around
using the iPhones and whatever but I and
and of course you've got globalization
to help you somewhat but I think I mean
we should go into for hours and hours I
think I think that it one of the
problems that you have is that you were
importing cheap goods from China all
these years and that's gonna stop so
there's gonna be all kinds of problems
we could go into and I spent hours and
hours thinking about it you know I'm a
bit of a workaholic and I read about it
a lot but you know and by the way I am
not the only one who I consider to be
real smart guy is saying just what I'm
saying I I mean you know if you read
some of these guys they're pretty damn
negative and myself lets you make the
point again about regulation absent the
kind of regulatory relief that you're
looking for what do you do you own these
refineries through this company which
you control called CDR correct yeah so
can you use CDR to do something else can
you do a roll up in the refinery
business buy up some other independent
refiners to try and find some economies
of scale that help you
whether what you term this this is sort
of a unique and almost insane problem
the EPA I mean it goes back a few years
but EPA has ruled at their great wisdom
that we the refineries are responsible
to deliver grids we're responsible to
think of it this way
we are responsible to blend a certain
amount of ethanol I'm not against
ethanol not for ethanol but we have to
blend it now that's obscured on the face
of it because the the people that use
the effort of all the gas stations for
the most part are owned by big oil or
owned by these huge chains so those guys
say well hey we're not gonna we're not
going to let you blend because we're not
going to buy your blended gasoline so
you say to the EPA how could I be
responsible for blended what I can't
sell my blended gasoline they say too
bad so they they say you have to deliver
to us a certain amount what they call
rinse rinse no I understand the problem
and it is a thorny one and as you have
pointed out in your letter to the EPA
there's speculation going on in that
market others have pointed out that
there's fraud going on in that market
and I don't want to get if you don't
mind Karl any more into it because it is
weedy but what about the alternatives
what do you do with a company like CBR
if you can't you know I have to tell you
we're a strong company ie straw company
but I'm not telling you that we're not
gonna have troubles as are many small
refineries so what's gonna happen is
they'll go bankrupt or taken over by big
oil when that happens and you take it
over you get an oligopoly so what the
EPA is doing I believe inadvertently is
doing what Big Oil could never do
themselves get rid of its competition
the FTC wouldn't let them do it I'd like
to see the FTC step in and stop this
crazy rid business so do so they are
doing for Big Oil what Big Oil could
never do for themselves so what's going
to happen is is in a few years they
these guys are on their backs and and
for we will be to look I made a lot of
money on this investment over the years
I'm not crying and certainly nobody's
gonna cry for me but what are you saying
was bit boil we'll take over these
companies and then all of a sudden would
be facing another problem as guess lean
prices go through the roof that's one
thing that may happen another thing
that's good but what is happening is and
I keep saying this rulings like this
what it's understood a battle and a lot
of companies thousands of CEOs
understand the problem they say one day
Regulatory Agency EPA waives its wand
and we're bankrupt or almost bankrupt
they'll lose it a fortune
why the hell should I invest abroad
capital why should our vegetable or
machinery therefore we can't compete and
therefore the the the middle class does
not have manufacturing jobs and we now
say well we're not a manufacturer we're
a service company now the thing that
goes for this country as you pointed out
is you know we're a we're a reserve
currency but I don't know how long you
could depend on that so I am just saying
that sooner or later there's gonna be a
massive problem I think I don't think I
don't see you backing down on the EPA
issue you pointed out earlier that
you've gone to battle with many a CEO
over the years and I'm thinking of last
year when you call for the breakup of
AIG AIG came back with another plan and
today they continued to execute on that
plan selling United guarantee for some
three and a half billion dollars my
question to you proud of it for that and
yo Peter and I I mean don't see either I
had everything but I really think that
he and I see eye to eye on what they
should be doing today i G and and I
supported him just recently when a few
people were really wanting me to really
go to battle and and I think he takes it
very seriously
I'm hopeful that he is going to do a lot
more of this and then do and now there
is a company there's a company Eric that
should do buybacks because they as they
get more cash their stock is so cheap
related to what they can buy it for and
they do have that money around and
there's no machinery they can buy you
know the AG doesn't barbed machinery
they there is the company that should do
buybacks oh okay each one is unique I
mean everyone shouldn't I can't say
every company should do it that's a good
one that you just mentioned can same
workers were on the board I just
believe hopefully the Peter I can't say
what that should do buy back so I set up
saying we're in the Hat of an investor
I'm not clearing the head of being on
the bullet you know you were you know
this was a I won't call it hostile
because maybe it didn't quite get to
that level on a technical in a technical
way but it was an adversarial position
you're now on the board is he moving
you're saying that he's moving fast
enough that he's brought you around to
the idea that AIG can take this sort of
incrementalist approach by selling
selling assets and then returning
capital yourself sort of interested you
probably you might not believe that you
know I go into these companies I see
unique things they should be doing I
think in certain cases we port with the
CEO for a while and then we become very
friendly or friendly I'm not telling you
we have Christmas dinner together but we
we Peggy Bay McDonald
you know we would again splitting it up
against went up against was up suddenly
he said I call you're right let's split
it up and split it up was great for sale
to look at PayPal PayPal is a great
company so he do you think is little by
little you know it's funny Tom wanted to
just what we said it took five years
with Bruce was hang on a second are you
saying that Hancock's gonna come around
to your idea that the company needs to
be broken up into three I'm not even
saying that because every one of my
ideas doesn't have to be followed to the
letter if if they've got does a general
thing which I believe should be done
okay I'm just talking general that if
you have a company there that has great
assets some of them I accept this
publicly so I can say it legacy assets
they could not make as much money as
other insurance companies on a lot of
these legacy assets they should be sold
and and AIG obviously sells at a lower
ratio than a lot of other insurance
companies I think once that is done I
think we have a good PN C company it
doesn't have to add a life company
itself yeah I think good part of that
life company should be so certainly part
of it in Japan so these are things I'm
saying you know I've said it before I'm
not going to get into what the board is
saying
are you still telling Peter that he
should fight the Civic designation you
should fight those Savita you know what
I can't go into more than that because
that's getting it to the bullet thing
like okay I know that's fair I shouldn't
be talking - no that's fair that's fair
yeah let me ask you about Allergan
though you just took a new position in
Allegan it was disclosed if I'm not
mistaken yesterday what do you want to
see happen there because as you know Dan
Loeb is an allergen
and John Paulson is an arrogant at least
as of the end of June is it just to sit
back and see what those guys do or do
you have a different one I really can't
talk about it I can't talk well if I you
know I don't what I don't talk about
what I'm buying and what I'm selling I
want to be clear but Allegan is a unique
situation that fell apart for the Pfizer
deal yeah yeah well the price appeal was
it well that mean it's a teleport Pfizer
and it was taught by the brush of
valiant and and it is that valiant okay
it's a separate different company the
valiant Redford is is it great see a
great excellent CEO I work with him as
Forrest
we made a fortune of forest once he got
to be the CEO and he so I look at him as
a great CEO he knows what he's doing
and with this die you know but I saw al
again you know after forest we made a
great deal of money with it finally got
that done and and and then when and I've
sold it and then it was higher they said
hey if it ever comes down I'm gonna do
it it then it fell apart because it was
really taught by the brush of a Liat and
it's not it is not value and and
therefore I bought the stock I think it
has a very good pipeline but I'm not
going to be on TV telling you people
should buy or sell it because I'm not
even telling you what I'm doing so you
know I just want to be clear on Allegan
so but I do think Brent is an excellent
CEO okay and and we've gotten along
great and I look a lot of these
companies we get into after a while they
you know they listen to the ideas we
have we've been around a long time and
we got friendly with him it's not like a
warfare all the time you know there's
war and peace had a us field a robbery
would use it years ago
said to be war beast called war piece we
had data every day for every rather
every month for seven eight years you
know I hope companies for eight years
and I guess so what I'm just telling you
this war this piece and and and you know
look at Motorola Greg Brown was a great
CEO there still is I think I don't own
it anymore but it was but he's done a
great job you did a great job so you
know these are good could take good
people and by the way I think the EPA
could be fine I really think that they
should just look at this thing and
become rational that's well I guess and
you don't think that there's any chance
that the EPA as it's currently
constituted might I'm just throwing it
out there might become more rational
might act differently in the Clinton
administration hey I sure hope so I I
hope that they changed the obligated
party in other words these RINs
shouldn't be an obligation on the
refinery can't ever find they ought to
clean up the rig market there's a rigged
market in it and and you know in any
other market you know set up by an
agency you don't you don't allow hedge
funds and speculators to come in and buy
the securities like the RINs
in this case you have a lot of smaller
and maybe larger a corners orders of
this of this winds at its absurdity and
this putting these comes in so you hope
that somebody will get rational look I
bet I've been able to when you work hard
on something and and we do have a bit of
the bully pulpit go in and get something
done get at least a rational trading in
the RINs make it make it unlawful for
speculators to come in and [ __ ] them
when you have an unregulated this is the
largest unregulated a trading I don't
even know what you call it a commodity
in the world you know my CEO just said
he's a funny guy he just told me on the
phone we were talking he said I said I
told the New York Times that interview I
hope because out he says you know if
Pablo Escobar were alive today he
wouldn't be doing coke he be trading
RINs
Carl one more before you before we go if
you don't mind federal
you want it to take it private the
minority stake that's held by the public
that you don't currently own it's
trading above your last offer you still
interested I can't talk about that what
to try